I'm saying I'm one of them dudes I can  walk in and some croco sex and and just  make it happen because I know what I'm  doing like I was your topic the swag is  kind of different when you know you you  got it like that you memorize orgasm  every single time absolutely really I  don't know that I know I put it down  when I see you trembling to the bathroom  time oh [ __ ] let me make you a sandwich  that means I [ __ ] put it down the  neck in other words how many minutes you  need with a woman to actually make her  will tremble like that it depends what  do you start what are you trying to  kinda get every woman every woman I've  ever been with could walk to the  bathroom perfectly yeah no not you got  to make sure that they are like jmd they  need a walker to get to the bathroom